let's face it we've all got control
issues they might keep us up at night
and sometimes they even limit our
ability to work with others
fortunately cloud storage bytes is here
to help well as long as your particular
control issues revolve around dealing
with and managing versioning in the
cloud
have you ever accidentally deleted a
file that you meant to keep what about
if someone else deletes your stuff it's
frustrating to say the least more
importantly imagine this experience for
your users fortunately you can course
correct and monitor potential accidental
data removal from your cloud storage
bucket
thanks to object versioning for a quick
review Google Cloud Storage uses object
versioning to protect your cloud storage
data from being overwritten or
accidentally deleted sounds great right
so let's get right into how this
versioning thing works object versioning
gets enabled on a bucket using gsutil or
the REST API once enabled cloud storage
creates an archived version of an object
each time the live version of the object
is overwritten or deleted that being
said if you move a file it effectively
loses its history so for example if I
have file cat with three versions and I
move cat to Chalker
then cat is still there with three
versions and now chunker is there with
one version but as far as cloud storage
can tell there's no connection showing
that chunker was once cat
as for overwritten or deleted objects
the archived version keeps the name of
the object but is uniquely identified by
a generation number all objects have
generation numbers associated with them
but only archived objects require
generation numbers to identify them
whenever object versioning is enabled
you can list archived versions of an
object restore the live version of an
object to an older state or permanently
delete an archived version as needed
using gsutil or the rest api you can
turn versioning on or off for a bucket
at any time turning off versioning
leaves existing object versions in place
but going forward the bucket stops
accumulating new archived object
versions Cloud Storage uses two
different properties that together
identify the version of an object one
property identifies the version of the
object's data the other property
identifies the version of the object's
metadata these
properties are always present with every
version of the object even if object
versioning is not enabled they can be
used as preconditions for conditional
updates to enforce the ordering of those
updates archived objects have their own
metadata which may differ from the
metadata of live objects most
importantly here is an archived version
retains its access control lists so it
may not necessarily have the same
permissions as the live version of that
same object each object whether live or
versioned has one set of metadata only
the latest meta generation numbers refer
to that metadata older meta generation
numbers cannot be used to access
metadata that has since been changed you
can update metadata for an archived
object by specifying its generation in
your request to ensure safe
read-modify-write semantics you can use
a meta generation matched precondition
using this precondition causes the
update to fail if the metadata you're
attempting to update was changed between
the time you read the metadata and the
time you sent the update now all of this
sounds pretty abstract so let's explore
an example let's see what happens to the
file cat in a bucket with object
versioning enabled as you overwrite
update move and delete the file you
start by uploading an image called cat
when you first upload cat to cloud
storage it receives a generation number
and a meta generation number in this
example the generation number is this
because the object is new the meta
generation number is one cat receives
generation and meta generation numbers
even though object versioning is not
enabled for instructions see the
documentation for viewing the object
metadata linked below now you decide to
enable object versioning for your bucket
this doesn't affect the generation or
meta generation numbers of cat but what
about when you update the metadata say
you update the metadata for cat by
adding a custom metadata color black
updating metadata causes the meta
generation value of cat to increase in
this case from 1 to 2
however the object itself remains
unchanged so cloud storage continues to
store only one version of cat and the
version still has the same generation
number now you upload a new version of
cat to your cloud storage bucket when
you do so object versioning moves the
existing cat object into an archive
state the archived version retains the
same storage class and metadata it
previously had the archived version
appears only if you perform a versioned
listing it does not appear in the normal
listing commands the archived version is
now referenced like this meanwhile the
newly uploaded cat becomes the live
version of the object this new cat gets
its own generation number it also gets
its own metadata and a meta generation
number of 1 which means it does not
contain the color black metadata unless
you specify it when you access or modify
cat this is the version that's used you
can alternatively refer to this version
of cat using its generation number for
example when using the GS util tool you
would refer to it with this file name
what if I decide to move cat to chunker
now when I view the archived versions I
find that cat is now fully archived the
meta generation number for chunker is 1
even though there were two versions of
cat when moving an object in cloud
storage you're actually making a copy
and then deleting the old version this
new object doesn't retain the versioning
data of the old one
ok you've decided you prefer dogs so you
delete chunker when you do this the
version that had this generation number
becomes archived your bucket now
contains two archived version of cat and
no live versions you can still refer to
either archived version by using its
generation number but if you try to
access cat without a generation number
it fails similarly a
normal object listing of the bucket will
not show cat as one of the objects in
the bucket for information on listing
archived versions of objects see listing
archived object versions linked below
you disable object versioning which
stops future object archiving existing
archived versions of objects remain in
cloud storage and even though object
versioning is disabled both cat versions
remain stored in your bucket until you
delete them either manually using the
command GS util RM or through using
object lifecycle management which is a
topic for a totally different video even
with object versioning disabled you can
restore one of the existing archived
versions by making a copy of it to do so
simply name the copy you make cat once
you do this your bucket has three
versions of cat the two archived
versions and the one live version that
came from making a copy and there you go
you can now manage versioning on your
own cloud buckets
on a sidenote do keep in mind that
enabling object versioning increases
storage costs this can be partially
reduced by configuring object lifecycle
management to delete older object
versions but that's for another episode
if you'd like to know more about
managing object versioning check out the
links in the description don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what you want to learn about Google
Cloud storage
thanks for joining us on this quick byte
of cloud storage see you next time
[Music]